I want to show you this this opening for
white and explain you some of the ideas
and so you can remember it so yeah why
it starts with a d4 and the opening I
want to show you it's called the Slav
defense black plays the move c6 as soon
as you play the move c6 now we know that
it's a Slav defense at this moment if
they ask you what's the name of the
opening we don't have an answer here
because there could be several different
openings here it could be for example D
takes c4 and who knows this opening
raise your hand the name of this opening
Queens gambit accepted correct which
opening is this here Queens gambit
declined so this is a Slav defense we're
going to go a little bit more and I want
to check how many openings you know some
of these openings okay raise your hand
first and which colors what is your
question we are doing this for white so
see the white is on your side so you're
learning this for white okay so this
opening for white so now there is
another opening here it's a pretty rare
opening I did a video earlier on this
opening so which opening is this after
c6 please take your seats guys
so what's the name of this opening it's
a bit of rare opening not a very very
common opening like Queens command
accepted or declined any ideas okay this
one is called chigorin defense okay
named after a very strong chess player
Russian chess player Qi Gordon okay so
remember this is Qi go in defense not a
very popular opening and also there is
one more opening the two more openings
actually Bishop f5 this is the Baltic
okay Baltic opening again bit rare
another idea is 'if I've and this is
this is I'll be gambit very good but
today we only going to focus on one
opening the Slav defense some of these
previous ones I've already done videos
on it you can search on a YouTube at the
Chess Club channel you will see those
irregular openings video that I talked
about this other openings but today
we'll look at the Slav defense and some
of this important ideas slot defense
it's not an easy opening to get an
advantage against when you're playing
with a white pieces so I will show you a
very simple method of obtaining a
slightly better position and having a
good game so you take C takes d5 this is
called the exchange variation of the
Slav defense so you take on d5 and this
is the exchange variation now he takes
back with a pawn
the next thing you want to do is you
want to develop your pieces so you will
start out with Knight f3
Knight f6 as you can see in like in a
previous class we develop our pieces
which is always very important 93 96 and
now we need to develop our Bishop before
we play this move like you play this
move III this is a bad move because now
you lock your Bishop so you never want
to do that in this opening you never
want to play this move III because then
you don't have any advantage here so
that's why here you play Bishop to f4
activating your Bishop and putting it on
this diagonal now White has many
different moves he can play here but
right now I want to talk about this
opening this move is six the point of
this move is to play Bishop d6 and just
try to develop the pieces and Castle you
will play e3 Bishop d6 and he's
proposing the exchange of the bishops
and now you have some options here what
do you think white should do here he can
exchange the bishops he can go Bishop g5
or you can do something else
yes
Bishop g3 absolutely this is the best
move because now you're telling you
basically if you want to exchange the
bishops he will take back you can take
back with the H pawn so if for example
Bishop takes g3 in this kind of
positions don't feel like this is
weakening your position because
sometimes players are under impression
that if you take back and you're going
to have doubled pawns it's always bad
here it's not bad actually it's good for
you because here your rook will actually
come into the game immediately so that's
why you want to capture with which pawn
here you have options here which piece
which point you want to capture with
here yes absolutely H takes g3 remember
90% of the time you go from the side
towards the center and that's what we're
doing right we're going from the sides
towards the center and only the 10% of
the time we're going to make this move
go from the center towards the side of
the board and this capture you will do
it in very rare cases where you have a
look on this file if you have a look on
this file and the route comes in into
the game then you can consider doing
that otherwise you go from the side
towards the center you have a question
it's possible gg3 is not a very good
move here because you don't want to put
you don't want to put too many pounds on
dark squares okay you don't want to put
too many parts on dark square pounds on
dark squares because that means your
light scores are going to be a weak okay
so it's possible somebody may have
played this move but it's not a very
good move this is the best move Bishop
g3 okay now he takes towards the center
block castles
now Bishop d3 he needs to be very
careful now after Bishop d3 because you
have some serious pressure on h7 and the
rook as well is putting pressure on this
but we're going to look at the move
let's say he plays b6 he's not being
careful here and now you can win this
game here if you start with the right
moves here you're going to win this game
here so let's think about it we don't
want to rush it we want to think a
couple of minutes to see how we can try
to activate more pieces here because we
have some pressure but it's not enough
to win we need to get a couple of more
pieces involved here and once we do that
then we're going to have excellent
chances to win here so which move we
have to try to go for here
okay yes you can't play Quincy - this is
but this is a more like a one move track
which is likely your opponent's we'll
see okay so you just made an attempt to
win this pawn but they will see it it's
just too simple for them to miss they
will just go here and that's it
you missed a moment okay so it's very
important to find the best move when you
have an opportunity here here you have a
very good opportunity here
okay any other few more people were
raising their hands yes you could do
that but do you have a follow up after
he takes back yeah that's why you gotta
be careful yeah I do we don't have
enough forces yet we need some more
forces to attack so now what is the move
here
what is the move here yes Knight g5 it's
similar it's similar to his suggestion
it's too obvious now your threat when
you make it so obvious unless I don't
have a way to defend it but here I have
actually a way to defend it it's too
obvious you just brought another piece
to attack and after this move I think
the best thing to do is come back now
and we lose temples temples is basically
time in chess you lose time okay so we
have to do something better we have to
do something that he cannot just counter
with so what we have here remember I
mentioned before in a previous class
some of you are here from that class
Knights belong we're in the center right
Knights belong in the center so do you
see a good move here
excellent night belongs in a center very
good move Knight goes to the center and
now when you do this your knight is very
active in the middle of the board and at
the same time now did you notice that
you open up this diagonal and something
really good going to happen because you
did that because you open up that
diagonal that was excellent
now he plays Bishop b7 and suddenly one
move before you weren't ready yet for
the tactics one more before you weren't
ready yet but now now you are now you
are ready to go for the mating attack
yesh let's see
very strong move here needed for white
to win this game okay go ahead
excellent Bishop h7 very good now there
is a difference because there's some
things are different now earlier you had
a knight here and the knight was
blocking you but now it's not so now if
it takes back what is the follow-up do
you see the follow-up do you see the
follow-up continue continue on your line
yeah but if you go with the rook he
takes back and then we lose some
material we still have an attack but we
lose so much here but you have something
better here you already expose the
position of the King here and now you
just need to bring more attacking forces
here close close but Queen d3 again you
want to bring it closer towards the
attack Queen d3 it's you know I can I
mean I can do something like this and
block it okay so you your that's that's
good but you have something better okay
you want to go towards the attack here
so what we have here let's see what's
the winning move here queen h5 excellent
basically what you accomplished here by
playing the move Bishop h7 you have
deflected the night from f6u deflected
this piece and now when he takes back
you go queen h5 and now you threaten to
take the line with checkmate you take it
with a checkmate now if he goes here if
it moves away do you see the mate yeah
okay queen h8 correct that's checkmate
right there now if he plays now rook e8
if he goes through he 8 now you have a
different kind of checkmate in two moves
different type of checkmate in two moves
here yes excellent job yes Queen f7
check King goes to the corner nine goes
on g6 checkmate this is actually you can
win like games like this I want a few
games like this as well and my students
too so it's a very common way to win
games if opponent doesn't know exactly
what he's doing
so King h8 here this is probably his
best move here and here you have a very
nice combination here you're not going
to be able to made him here but you're
going to win a lot on material here so
you're going to win his Queen here and
then you know you will eventually either
he will resign or you will convert it
into a checkmate but but let's see if
you can find that the beautiful
combination to win the Queen here so
let's see I want to give you some time
to think so the goal here is to find a
way to win the Queen because we can
really check made him here let me tell
you it's one to treat the form of
combination here take this you could you
think okay but let me explain something
when you were attacking piece you're
when you're attacking somebody trying to
made them you don't want to exchange
pieces because every time you exchange
that will reduce your attacking forces
you understand keep your material try to
use it don't exchange because exchange
you want to do when the position is
simple you're winning on a material then
you can do that but here you don't wanna
go you
want to keep the material okay let's see
here aha that's good
continue now your three moves away here
three moves away thanks remember the
Queen age five doesn't work my knight is
here so now what are we going to do here
now it's a nice combination here
nice combination here let's see yes
correct now he takes but you have to
continue here don't touch nothing
tink tink tink tink I know you want to
do that but then he takes you back
that's okay but that's not your best
okay that's good but remember when you
see a good move you look for a better
one right who say that which world
champion say that huh yes okay let me
finish that that was a manual a skier
world champion number three say that
when you see a good move look wait for a
better one your move was good night f7
okay but there is something yeah Queen
h5 there's a night here then sit down
please and just raise your hand now who
is going to find a brilliant idea now
okay
Luke h8 so basically it's another decoy
or deflection alai dia forcing the king
to take and after he does that you take
his rook and do you see now what we have
here it's a fork it's a fork and he goes
here you take the Queen and you win the
game okay well I mean if you play well
you will win after this you're up you're
up a queen you know so we expect you're
gonna win this okay we expect it then
you will win this okay very good
so this is what you learn on the opening
ok the slob defends exchange violation
let's see now if you remember this okay
so this is the position I want you to
reach so now we're going to go back
we're going to put in a training mood
and see if you can get here okay you can
actually reach this position playing
this new opening that you learn today
okay let's see raise your hand if you
remember the first move that I showed
you here and we're going to go on like
that and review this okay the first move
here what was the first move here the
first move yes okay second move what was
the second move
c4 remember here what's the name of the
opening if they ask you that question
what do you say right now I think you
came a little late you didn't see this
part so at this moment what's the name
of the opening
very good we don't know yet we don't
know yet we need one more move okay and
then okay how many different openings
black can play here you remember it was
four or five yeah so let's make sure
everybody knows this okay
now so it looks like actually six but
okay so if it takes now which opening is
this very popular very popular opening
excellent if you place this one I go by
the good ones first so if you place this
one this is declined and here we already
know this one this is what what opening
is this Slav defense Slav defense now
and look at the irregular ones now if it
was here now what opening is this the
rare name yeah rare name little bit this
one Russian name yeah she got in she go
in defense now if it goes this one more
rare than she go in this is which one is
this Baltic excellent and now if he
plays the e5 the last one this is a
gambit what kind of gambit is this in
the back no it's it's something else
something else it's it's all been all
being counter gambit okay counter gambit
Albin okay back to the Slav defense
so what move we play now which line we
go to here there are many different ways
you can play it but we want to branch
out to this one line that we can get
comfortable position in excellent what's
the name of this line remember the name
of the line it's Slav defense the
opening but now when you take this is
the name of a line that's
code excellent exchange variation of the
Slav defense remember you take something
when you take something in opening early
stages it's likely the name is going to
be exchanged okay it's going to involve
that exchange variation okay
now and we got to develop pieces right
we got to develop our pieces we got to
get our Knights now yes
now continue continue developing your
pieces yes you
and now which move you absolutely have
to play here before you play III which
move you have to play excellent Bishop
to f4
now after we play Bishop f4 we can play
now he's trying to exchange the bishops
here now we have to play it correctly
here we have to play it correctly yes
excellent
he takes now we have options here right
how do we capture here huh how do we
capture we have two different ways to
capture here now how do we do it
from the side towards the center now
castles and now which piece now needs to
be developed tink tink where remember I
think you want to go somewhere else
right because here you don't want to go
here right he'll take you right remember
you want to put pressure on this pawn so
you're going to put it where of course
yeah should be three remember that was
the Bishop d3 to attack now I played b6
and this is going to cost them this move
because now his position is going to get
weak because now remember Knights belong
where Knights belong in the center right
in the center yes excellent excellent
move 95 now he protects it and now your
diagonal is open and you are ready now
to start the attack in the back now
that's the following move you can move
right away the knight will take you what
you have to do first to deflect the
knight remember you make a move to
deflect him first
how are we going to deflect
very good that's called deflection he
takes back now and now you are ready to
bring your which piece in Queen h5
excellent now he moves the knight
checkmate immediately and if he goes
here if he goes away now checkmate in
two right perfect very good and the last
one here is from King h8 and if you
place King h8 you have to remember the
winning sequence here okay this is took
a little bit of time because it's not as
obvious here okay it took a little bit
of time here check first remember check
first now you force it to go back to g8
and now what's the next move now now we
have pressure your same idea we have
more pressure yes you could do that but
let's keep the knife we might need it
for something else let's maybe keep the
knight for now which piece can we use
here instead of the night huh which
piece let's see okay yes
that's the difficult move to find rook
to h8 okay because if you take the
knight the rook is just going to take it
so you go rook to H a check your fortune
this is called deflection decoy okay you
he has to move now deflection so you
just take and once he does this what is
the move don't rush are you rushing now
but you have that but look at the knight
now deflection was done to do what
deflection was done to so we can freely
take this right and then what do you say
this what is this fork fork or double
attack fork okay very good okay that's
the idea for this one so you learn how
to do deal with a slab defense